today I assume the role of candy cane
chomping Douglas MacArthur in the war on
Christmas does it exist are we winning I
will explain why the war on Christmas
really matters and I will be wearing
this helmet the whole time in case any
lefties try to break in and attack me
with euphemistic language plus the
mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is there a war on Christmas before we
get into it I have to talk about some
Christmas presents it is Christmas time
so the first thing I want to talk about
our movement watches you can see I'm
wearing it any great general has to wear
any great cultural general has to wear a
watch into battle to know what time it
is and what end is up movement does this
really really well
holiday shopping can be very tough
thanks to movement all that gift-giving
anxiety can disappear with the press of
a button these watches make the perfect
purchase for any guy in your life they
really do they're so sleek they're very
fashionable they also start at just 95
dollars so if you went into a department
store to get a watch like this you'd
probably be paying three hundred four
hundred dollars movement has innovated
they've shaken up the whole watch
industry by selling direct to you online
you can finish your holiday shopping and
get a movement watch for someone on your
list now the company was started by
these two Broke college kids who wanted
to wear nice stylish watches but they
they couldn't afford them as bro college
kids or want to do so they started their
own watch company you know this is
American ingenuity that's finest it's a
great great time and a great price point
for Christmas you can give someone a
really high-quality gift for a
reasonable price they begin at $95 and
at such great prices they you know
there's classic design there's quality
construction
there's styled minimalism you don't
usually get that for under a hundred
bucks so I would take advantage of this
they've sold over 1 million watches in
160 countries and today this christmas
came early for you guys because you will
get 15% off plus free shipping and free
returns by going to mV mt dot-com / co'
f f/a that is CoV fe fe MVM t.com / co f
f/a i recommend doing it just to type in
the promo code I think you'll like the
watch is when you get there it's got a
clean design great fashion statement now
is the time to step up your watch game
and to step up the watch game of that
man in your life who just you know
doesn't keep track of time doesn't
doesn't really dress like an adult
adults should be wearing
watches MVM t.com / co' FFA CoV f EF e
join the movement so is there a war on
Christmas of course there's a war on
Christmas stop trying to be a cool guy
and get the New York Times to like you
by pretending there isn't there
obviously is it's now fashionable in
some conservative circles where people
care what the New York Times thinks to
say that the war on Christmas is some
crazy illusion of conservatives and I'm
you know I'm not that kind of
conservative no no I'm educated and
fancy and I think wait wait don't tell
me is clever I'm not one of those middle
state rubes who pays attention to the
degraded culture belched out every year
by our sophisticated betters on the
coasts stop it
stop it you're embarrassing yourself of
course there is a war on Christmas to
begin here's the first bit of evidence
Barack Obama struck the word Christmas
from the White House Christmas card a
quick look back through history shows
this is not the norm Calvin Coolidge
wrote in his 1927 White House Christmas
card the real spirit of Christmas if we
think on these things there will be a
born in us a savior and over us will
shine a star sending its gleam of Hope
to the world
FDR wrote some variation of Merry
Christmas from the President and mrs.
Roosevelt each of the 150 years he
reigned in the White House Harry Truman
wrote quote as 1950 ebbs - it's close
our hearts turned once more to Bethlehem
and to the coming of a little child the
divine infant that brought love to a
weary world six paragraphs later six
paragraphs later he concluded quote
glory to God in the highest and on earth
peace good will peace and goodwill
toward men Eisenhower wrote a curt
typical season's greetings for Christmas
and New Year JFK happy Christmas the
pieces of LBJ's card available still
don't show the wording but given his
preference for four-letter epithets
that's probably for the best language on
the other cards is hard to track down as
well until we get to George W Bush who
included verses from Psalms on the
Christmas card then we get to Barack
Obama who not only struck mention of
Christmas entirely but according to his
own White House social secretary tried
to ban the crash than nativity scene
from the East Room of the White House
now why would you do that you ask why
would he want to do that
because they wanted to make Christmas
more quote inclusive that's the line
offered by the way that's how you know
that there is a war on Christmas the
school districts will replace Merry
Christmas and Happy New Year with the
vague Happy Holidays retail outlets work
environments Christmas parties have
become vague holiday parties in many
circles particularly in the cultural
centers of the country just say Merry
Christmas has become a political act
that expresses to the retail worker or
the acquaintance your political and
politically incorrect point of view and
if you harp on this long enough as I do
as I do every year you will inevitably
get the same reply well yeah but why
shouldn't the greeting be more inclusive
you know not everybody celebrates
Christmas you know and and that's the
moving of the goal posts first there
wasn't a war on Christmas now there is
but it doesn't matter that's how you
know the other trick that those who deny
the cultural movement will say is that
it isn't a war the language it's
hyperbolic it's ridiculous there isn't a
war you don't say there is it there
aren't guns that's true there aren't
tanks and bullets Christmas is not
literally being cut down by machine gun
fire that's because the war on Christmas
is a figure of speech
much like the war on poverty say poverty
is not being cut down by bullets because
like Christmas it isn't material what is
meant by the quote war on Christmas is a
battle of language and culture there is
a belligerent group of left-wing
cultural warriors which seeks to replace
clear traditional precise language
Christmas with vague meaningless
euphemisms like happy holidays and
season's greetings of course both
phrases have been around for a long time
but whereas in the past they referred
specifically to Christmas and New Year's
like like Eisenhower's Christmas card
season's greetings for Christmas and New
Year now they serve as a replacement for
the politically correct term what the
modern mind considers the grave offense
of Christmastime Merry Christmas but
aren't there other major holidays during
Christmas time beside Christmas and New
Year's this is usually what they ask now
really there are holidays to be sure but
no major ones
the closest contender we have is
Hanukkah which is the Jewish festival of
lights
but while Hanukkah is indeed an ancient
holiday it dates back about 2,000 years
it is a relatively
holiday major Jewish holidays are
biblical they feature restrictions on
work because Hanukkah is non biblical
there are few religious restrictions on
work according to historian Diane Ashton
Hanukkah rose to prominence in America
as it did not in the rest of the world
because of to reform rabbis in 19th
century Cincinnati who worried their
children had a little connection to the
synagogue before that there is a little
record of Chanukah celebrations
the rabbi's modeled the celebration in
gift-giving after Christmas as Ashton
explains quote they didn't see Christmas
as something they could do easily
because it's Christian but they did want
to do something like that because it was
American
so kosher restaurants even started
serving turkey dinners after the
American custom that's Hanukkah the far
less credible Pretender is Kwanzaa which
is a socialist contrivance invented by a
criminal LA City College Africana
Studies professor named Maulana Karenga
in 1966 he created Kwanzaa to be a
holiday specifically for black americans
even though black americans already
celebrated christmas ironically while
virtually all African slaves were
brought to America from the west coast
of Africa Kwanzaa is a Swahili word
meaning first fruits that originated in
East Africa which means none of the
slaves brought to America would have
understood it now one of the seven
principles of Kwanzaa is communism
bujjamma cooperative economics and
Maulana Karenga himself was sentenced to
prison in 1971 for felonious assault and
false imprisonment after he sexually
assaulted and tortured multiple women as
the LA Times reported he ordered them to
strip naked whipped them with an
electrical cord and beat them with the
karate baton Karenga then placed a hot
soldering iron in one woman's mouth and
against her face and tightened her big
toe and a vise he finally put detergent
and running hoses in their mouths and
hit them on the head with toasters as
the Black Power movement of the 1970s
has waned so too has the celebration of
the holiday on the high end of estimates
0.3 percent of Americans acknowledge the
supposed holiday that rate continues to
decline so why pretend Christmas time
does not center around Christmas why
pretend there are so many other major
holidays on equal footing there's new
year on January 1st and we've long said
good tiding for Christmas and a Happy
New Year there
Chanukah a relatively minor holiday but
by the way we don't say happy holidays
instead of happy Labor Day
even though Rosh Hashanah which is a far
more important Jewish holiday than
Chanukah sometimes occurs around the
same time you don't say that we don't
say happy holidays or season's greetings
instead of happy Columbus Day
even though Yom Kippur another much more
important Jewish holiday sometimes
occurs around that time well actually
now we don't say happy Columbus Day
either we say blessed indigenous peoples
day or something like that
that's another story beer is Kwanzaa
virtually non-existent holiday what else
is there there's Boxing Day in which no
one in the United States celebrates
there's the winter solstice which people
pretend as a thing but nobody celebrates
and of course it isn't about the the
celebrants of Hanukkah or Kwanzaa or the
winter solstice who are waging the war
on Christmas it's the Atheist left who
constantly seeks to replace clear vivid
language with bizarre secular euphemisms
this is the essence of political
correctness that the essence of
political correctness is to replace
clear language with euphemisms to remove
the strength of that language so we have
abortion abortion isn't the killing of
babies in the womb it's women's
reproductive health assisted suicide
isn't killing the old and the sick
it's euthanasia the euthanasia is a word
that literally means good death the good
day you know it's good it's nice so it's
no surprise that is political
correctness reached peak potency in the
late 1990s and early 2000s we see the
war on Christmas Denver banned religious
floats from its Christmas parade New
York Mayor Mike Bloomberg displayed the
city's holiday tree major department
stores like Macy's removed references to
Christmas public schools began removing
Christian symbols from Christmas time
display all around this time how
coincidental
now the left alternately denies that the
war on Christmas exists and then when
they can't deny it any longer they say
it doesn't matter who cares who cares
it's just language you're just arguing
over semantics sure but semantics means
meaning if the language doesn't matter
then why are the war on Christmas
belligerents so insistent on changing
the traditional clear and precise
language if it doesn't matter then great
great that's phat perfect Merry
Christmas and Happy New Year for
about happy holidays but of course
language matters of course those who
insist on the bizarre vague euphemisms
they know precisely that because
politics sits downstream of culture you
know who else knows that as President
Trump here he is on the campaign trail
you know we're getting near that
beautiful Christmas season that people
don't talk about anymore they don't use
the word Christmas because it's not
politically correct you go department
stores and they'll say Happy New Year
and they'll say other things and it'll
be red they'll have it painted but they
don't say well guess what we're saying
Merry Christmas again this was a great
promise people didn't really take it
seriously because they don't take these
language issues seriously but here is
President Trump as president Christmas
story begins 2,000 years ago with a
mother a father their baby son and the
most extraordinary gift of all the gift
of God's love for all of humanity
whatever our beliefs we know that the
birth of Jesus Christ and the story of
this incredible life forever changed the
course of human history each and every
year at Christmastime we recognize that
the real spirit of Christmas
what we have it's about who we are each
one of us is a child of God that is the
true source of joy this time of the year
that is what makes every Christmas Mary
and now as the president of the United
States
it's my tremendous honor to finally
which America and the world a very Merry
Christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
there's nothing like just sitting here
with a little candy cane pipe and
watching that that is pretty good and
there's good news the great news in the
war on Christmas is the clear language
and tradition are finally winning after
decade or a decade and a half according
to a 2005 Gallup poll 41 percent of
respondents deferred to happy holidays
over Merry Christmas ten years later a
similar survey albeit through a
different Research Center found that
number had dropped to just 25 percent
the last two years have brought a
cultural exuberance to the right and
it's given us myriad early Christmas
presents
tax reform originalist judges
responsible foreign policy massive
deregulation Obamacare mandate repeal
the list goes on and on now all of this
has been possible because of a cultural
shift in the country away from insidious
euphemisms and political correctness
they've the pinnacle of insidious
euphemisms now is not the time to
retreat or seek the approval of the New
York Times David McCullough observed
that to write well is to think clearly
and that's why it's so hard don't give
in to fashionably muddled thinking
especially around the incarnation of the
divine logic himself now back to
Christmas presents before we enter the
mailbag back to Christmas presents
because I have just gotten my favorite
Christmas presents so far of the year
ever you might have seen this if you
watch Andrew Klavan show you got to
unpack a man crate this is from man
crates and it was this box it comes and
it's it's gift wrapped in duct tape and
it comes in a giant crate and it comes
with a crowbar and you open up your box
that way and they have these excellent
gifts for men so I know it's very hard
to pick out the perfect gift for
everybody
you know it's very easy to get it wrong
you feel bad if you don't put any
thought into it man crates calm is the
surest way to find gifts that guys will
actually love guaranteed the wreath I
have been begging by the way for this
sponsor for a while now because I wanted
a man great this is not a cheese of the
Month Club it's not a new Thai Club they
offer over 100 hand curated gift
collections for every type of guy from
the rugged outdoorsman to the sports
fanatic and everything in between so the
one that I got is the whiskey
appreciation crate which is phenomenal
Clavin got the same one gives you a
personalized whiskey decanter
personalized whiskey glasses a bunch of
nuts and the you know bar food basically
a great little whiskey companions
there's the grillmaster crate with a
brass knuckle meat tenderizer and a cast
iron smoker box man crates calm you pick
the perfect crate for you or your your
loved one
I say loved one but really you're gonna
look and get it for yourself you choose
the delivery date when the crate arrives
you get to pry it open with a laser
engraved crowbar men's health and Allure
magazine which do not agree on much both
say that man crates are the perfect gift
for men they have thousands of five-star
reviews it comes with a high-five
guarantee you can own the holidays now
today if you go to man crates dot-com
slash Knowles k nowl es you'll get five
percent off of your order and they don't
offer this discount anywhere else that's
man crates calm slash Knowles kayo wles
if you if you don't want to get too
creative with these gifts and you don't
want to go for the whiskey set or the
brass knuckle meat tenderizer or
whatever you can get a gift card I know
everyone gets gift cards everyone
probably wants gift cards it's the
easiest thing to get but when you get a
gift card through man crates com they
deliver it with a sledgehammer and it's
in a block of cement so you have to
smash your block of cement to get your
present and that is really the essence
of the of giving a gift it's not really
so much about the thing itself it's
about the experience of it the
relationship between you know you and
the person and it's it's a really great
experience and yeah highly recommended
so go to man crates calm slash Knowles
okay I'm gonna put down my candy cane
pipe and we're going to get into the
mailbag first question from David hi
Michael first
I'd like to point out I'm a big fan of
your show Thanks you had made an
argument for venerating Mary I
understand
having great respect to Mary as the
woman chosen by God to bear Jesus in
human form but I'm curious as to how it
is praying to Mary not conflict with the
first two Commandments I myself am a
Christian based my faith on Scripture
and use Scripture as the basis to
evaluate practices ideologies etc thanks
David a good time of year to be asking
that question you know I think a lot of
this boils down to this question that
some Protestants ask which is why would
you pray to anybody why not just pray
directly to Jesus why would you pray for
two Saints or why would you have people
on earth pray pray to you in Revelation
chapter 5 here's a verse and when he had
taken it the four living creatures in
the 24 elders fell down before the lamb
each one had a harp and they were
holding golden bowls full of incense
which are the prayers of God's people so
we have the Saints offering prayers to
God in heaven they're offering prayers
for what they're not offering prayers
for themselves they're in heaven they're
offering prayers for other people so as
early as the the 1st century of the
Christian tradition we see people asking
for intercession praying for
intercession and we we have the City of
God the Saints who are in heaven praying
for those of us who aren't there yet or
who need our their prayers we have 1st
Timothy from Paul which is
pseudepigrapha but it might tell you
something certainly we still read first
timothy quote first of all then i urge
that supplications prayers intercessions
and thanksgiving be made for all men for
kings and all who are in high positions
that we may lead a quiet and peaceable
life godly and respectful in every way
this is good and pleasing to God our
Savior who desires all men to be saved
and to come to the knowledge of the
truth now paul asks others to pray for
him all the time in Romans and Fe's
Colossians that first Thessalonians 2nd
Thessalonians and he prayed for others
we see that in 2nd Thessalonians
Christ Himself tells us to pray for
others he says quote love your enemies
and pray for those who persecute you why
wouldn't he tell them I'll just have
them pray to me directly
no he says you have to pray for others
pray to whom prayed
Jesus regularly supplies for one person
based on the faith of another person so
in Matthew we see Christ says a woman
great is your faith be it done for you
as you desire and her daughter is healed
so it's not the daughter praying at
someone interceding for the daughter and
praying and based on the woman's faith
the daughter the daughter is healed we
don't hear about the daughter's faith we
only hear about the mother's faith
Matthew you know another in Matthew lord
have mercy on my son for he has seizures
and he suffers terribly in mark teacher
I brought my son to you that he has a
spirit that makes him mute in Luke do
not fear only believe and she your
daughter will be well
so one thing we also know from James is
that the prayers of the righteous work
especially well so James says the prayer
of a righteous man has great power in
its effects
we know that Mary is quite righteous she
there's the Immaculate Conception she
was selected to be the Ark of the New
Covenant to give birth to the
Incarnation to our risen Lord seems to
me she would be a good person to pray
for you as well I think that's a lot of
words I think probably you could answer
that question by saying she's the mother
of Jesus she's the mother of God but
that I hope that clears it up a little
bit because very often I think people
say well I don't think we should do
these rituals or these traditions or
have this liturgy because it's not in
Scripture but actually it is in
Scripture it does come from Scripture
the liturgy comes from Scripture and you
just have to read a little more more
broadly or more closely to see exactly
how that fits in it's not always clear
to people who aren't in the tradition
itself
next question from Brigid hey Michael so
I've made a bit of a political come
around in 2016 due to all the election
craziness I was pretty far to the left
in most ways and still am on a lot of
economical issues but I've recently
become more devout in my Catholic faith
and have changed my position from
pro-choice to pro-life I'm afraid to
tell my pro-choice friends and family
because I'm afraid they'll ostracize me
I was wondering if you had any advice I
do this is hard this is a hard thing
happened to me I was pro-choice back
when I was I wasn't really left-wing but
I was pro-choice I'm from New York New
York Republicans are just not terribly
conservative as I got more conservative
was clear to me that abortion isn't good
and we shouldn't have to have it be a
legal thing Diana Schaub who's a
bioethicists convinced me of this over a
lunch and when it happened I didn't know
how to tell my friends the way you have
to do it is two things unapologetically
and patiently don't apologise the left
sees pro-life as anti woman and they
really earnestly believe that it's not
just some joke and so you you have to be
unapologetic you have nothing to
apologize for
but you also have to be patient with
them they're not going to understand be
calm
usually the first person to get angry
and start screaming and argument is the
one who doesn't understand really what
you're arguing over so be patient be
calm about it and you know louis c.k had
a good bid on this louis c.k that majus
greatest comedian but he had a good bid
he said you know abortion i don't think
it's a big deal it's like going to the
bathroom it's just going to the bathroom
it's not a big deal or it's killing a
baby it's it's either completely
meaningless like excretion or it's
murdering a baby and I think you have to
explain those premises because if you
explain those premises and it's
perfectly logical and compassionate from
there and then you just debate the
premise is this baby in the womb is it
is it living yes is it human yeah it's
not a dog it's not a giraffe it's human
so it's a is it independent or as a part
of the mother it's independent it has
its own genome it will develop into its
own personality it has a beating heart
within not very many days it's obviously
independent or a separate rather it's
obviously dependent for food on its
mother and so if all of those things are
true then the question is are you
willing to risk what what is the moral
equivalent of murder because you on the
premise that it doesn't yet have human
dignity when you're going to abort it if
you put it in those terms I think you
might not bring them totally to
understanding but they'll begin to
understand the premises okay we have a
lot more to talk about we have so much
more mailbag but I gotta say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube thank you for being
with me and serving in the war on
Christmas go forth troops go on you know
and fight the
secular language transforming opponents
on the other side but if you are
subscribed to the daily wire go over
there right now daily wire.com and you
can watch the rest of the show you also
if you subscribe right now you will be
ready for the conversation with none
other than the boss man himself ben
shapiro
that conversations gonna be next Tuesday
5:00 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific I you
can
if you subscribe you can ask questions
but everybody can watch only subscribers
can ask questions if you subscribe what
do you get you get me you get the intro
flavin show you got the Ben Shapiro show
no ads on the website you get to talk to
the conversation that's great
forget about all that it's Christmas
time this is the most coveted objects
gift in the entire world I know you're
not going to give it to your friends as
a gift it's too desirous it's too
wonderful
Al Franken resigned today the leftist
tears are gonna be flowing left right
and center make sure you have this or
else you're going to drown you can have
them hot or cold always salty and
delicious go to the Daily wire calm
right now we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
next question from Steven season's
greetings how do I answer my leftist
friends who point to studies that show
disparities in criminal sentencing
between blacks and whites there do seem
to be a few that show more time for
similar convictions thank you for your
time
this is we you shouldn't dismiss this
out of hand this is a real issue there's
a 2014 study that showed blacks are more
likely to be jailed while awaiting trial
what does this mean
when you look into this it seems that
it's largely because a lot of those
people can't afford to post bail
so the wealthier people who are jailed
can post bail but these poor people can
and that creates racial disparities
there's also evidence that shows blacks
serve longer sentences one of the
reasons behind this is ironically or
mandatory minimums so mandatory minimums
have an important motive they have good
motive but the road to hell is paved
with good intentions it's the idea that
certain crimes are so bad you they have
to have a minimum sentence and then it's
you can play around with it from there
and it's up to the judge and it's up to
the parole board or whatever but the
mandatory minimums seem to have created
some racial inequality we saw this in
the drug war drugs like crack cocaine
were punished much more harshly than
drugs like regular cocaine I don't think
there's any particularly racist reason
for this crack cocaine is much worse
it's much more dangerous to individuals
and communities nevertheless it creates
disparities in drug sentencing the thing
that you should begin with here when
you're talking to your friend is to
suggest that perhaps the cause of these
disparities is not the man it's not
institutional racism it's not an
intentional move on the part of the
government or white people or whatever
to create racial disparities and to
imprison black people the situation is
obviously more complex we've just talked
about two examples of this so if the
situation is more complex then we need
to look at what is causing these
disparities are they political then
perhaps we can fix them are they
cultural you can fix them but that's
much harder you need to know what the
issues are they might be Geographic and
just tell them to hold their judgment
for one second
and if you don't take the easy silly
answer that it's institutional racism I
think you're more likely to arrive at a
serious answer and then you can fix the
problem
next question from Evan dear master
Knowles is Santa Claus Saint Nicholas or
Saint Christopher because of Kris
Kringle Merry Christmas Evan I know he's
not a Saint Christopher he is Saint
Nicholas jolly old Saint Nick I love st.
Nicholas he was a third century Bishop
from Asia Minor there's a legend around
him that says he frequently gave secret
presents to people and that's where we
got part of the Christmas story from but
forget that forget the presents forget
him giving man crates to people and
stuff the best story of jolly old Saint
Nick is he punched a heretic at the
first Council of Nicaea the first
Council of Nicaea they're debating the
divinity of Christ and Saint Nicholas
jolly old Santa Claus got so angry by
the nonsense arias was preaching that he
got up and punched him in the face so
there are a few memes that go around
every Christmas season one says quote I
came to give presents to kids and punch
heretics and I just ran out of presents
and then the other which is my favorite
is he sees you when you're sleeping he
knows when you're awake he knows if
you've denied the divinity of Christ so
if you're an Arian duck that's Saint
Nicholas great guy worth reading about
he also was martyred pretty brutally
viciously tortured and killed and we
commemorate him by giving each other
candies and sweaters and things so worth
reading about the guy a wonderful saint
and gave a santa claus next email is
from Luke what is the best response to
atheists who say it's irrational to
believe in a God because when you make
an assertion you have to prove it in
other words you have to prove a positive
you have to avert the burden of proof is
on the believer this is something
Christopher Hitchens and the new
atheists like to say this isn't so this
is not true first of all a one point you
might bring up to these people is that
every culture around the entire world
for all of time has believed in a
remarkably similar version of divinity
and metaphysics and God that is a little
strange it seems to be baked into
humanity just as thirst is baked in just
as hunger is baked in and then the
second thing I would point out
take so many things on faith all the
time this is evidence that a little bit
of learning is a dangerous thing
people have learned a very basic version
of induction or a very basic version of
the scientific method and so they think
that you can prove everything using the
scientific method but obviously this
breaks down when you get to the
scientific method itself it breaks down
at reason so what are some axiom in
mathematics there are a lot of axiom
rather v axiom you have to assume that a
equals a with it if a doesn't equal a
you can't perform mathematics right you
have to assume that if a equals B then B
equals a if a equals B then B and B
equals C then a equals C right if a
equals B then a plus C equals B plus C
right you can't prove that those are
just axia those are the building blocks
even for reason you can't make an
argument for reason so I can say well
I'm gonna prove that my faculties of
reason are reliable I'm going to prove
logical argument but you can't do it
because the only way that you could do
that is to make a logical argument and
it begs the question it assumes the
conclusion in the premise of the
question you can't prove it yesterday
existed there are many many things that
you can't prove that you take on faith
so what you have to parse are those
aspects of theology that B we can reason
through and you know Thomas Aquinas did
a pretty good job of this and many
others and and where ultimately reasoned
butts up against what can only be
bridged by revelation and faith and you
can read plenty of logical people to
bring you to that point to describe it
to you but I this is the the evidence of
a little learning is a dangerous thing
Christopher Hitchens you used language
very well so people thought that he was
making good points but he wasn't making
any points his book God is not great
doesn't even make that point it's a book
about how terrible religion is but it
doesn't argue what he pretends the
thesis is it's very clear the Atheist
thesis it's very clear well I can't see
God so he doesn't exist but shallows are
clear and shallow thinking is clear so
don't think a little harder than that
and maybe ask yourself why is it that
everybody throughout all of history
practically
and all of the great geniuses have
believed in God why is it that Isaac
Newton spent the last 30 years of his
life interpreting Scripture why is that
the Blaise Pascal believed so much that
he offered the great wager he was a
devotedly Christian Francis Bacon live
Nets girdle all the great scientists and
mathematicians why is it that they all
believed why is it that Bertrand Russell
the greatest magician of the 20th
century couldn't make an argument
against the ontological argument for
God's existence I'm seeing a lot of
coincidences here so tell them to think
a little more deeply about it and point
out all of the faith that they take
anyway that they don't even know about
next question Michael this should be an
easy question for me to answer but it
doesn't come to me quickly the founding
fathers believed all men are created
equal but also created the 3/5 clause
this is a hypocritical situation if the
founding fathers violated the very thing
that this country was built on why
should we honor their documents views
history etc thank you
there's nothing hypocritical about them
there is nothing hypocritical about
saying all men are created equal and
then those same men for purposes of
reality of creating this government
compromising their philosophical purism
to create a country that would get rid
of that institution in fairly short time
this is a conflict I think between
philosophical idealism and metaphysical
realism it's an error that the
rationalists fall into so they think
well I have this purity of thought and
they kind of preen about it and they get
on their moral high horse and then
whenever men real people in the real
world do something that doesn't live up
to their philosophical purity they say
ah you hypocrite you're I'm pure I'm but
you haven't done anything of course
you're not it doesn't make you pure
those men were some of the greatest men
in American history at the
Constitutional Convention and they're
great because they had philosophical
purity and they also dealt in reality
it's a very important and a look in the
Constitution they built in a provision
that within a short number of years they
would stop the importation of slaves
from Africa that this question of
slavery was already built-in and by the
way the three-fifths compromise
was a compromise too I suppose in a way
help the black slaves but really the
question had little to do with the
slaves themselves it had everything to
do with representation between the North
and the South in the Federation in the
in the United States so the South wanted
to count black slaves as citizens for
the purpose of population numbers in
representation in Congress but not count
them as citizens when it comes to giving
civil rights to citizens so they had no
rights but they wanted more
representation and the northerners said
that's ridiculous if you don't treat
these people as human and you don't
treat them as citizens you don't get to
count them as population and they
arrived at this compromise to create the
greatest most free most equal most fair
most just most prosperous nation in the
history of the world that has given
countless benefits philosophical and
material to the citizens that were
excluded and were harmed and oppressed
and also to the rest of the world since
then so I wouldn't call them hypocrites
I'd I'd always take a look at the man in
the mirror and say I am I am I better
than John Adams am I better than Thomas
Jefferson have I have I done anything
great for the word health like those
guys did and I think you'll find no
probably not
next question dear Cardinal Mike I'm a
Protestant and I believe that communion
is an important ritual but I don't
believe in transubstantiation
that's the that the bread becomes the
body and blood of Christ
why do Catholics think Christ was being
literal when he called it his flesh and
blood but they don't take other
Christian rituals literally for example
they don't believe baptism causes
someone to be physically born-again what
would happen if we scientifically
analyzed the bread and wine at the
bottom of someone's stomach thanks and
love the show Justin this is a good
question why is this difference so Jesus
says you have to be born again in the
baptism but the context is important
here because he speaks in John were just
like the Bible isn't genre it's not all
literal history it's not all poetry it's
not all philosophy so at that time when
he says you have to be born again we
don't see people being born again we
don't he doesn't say you have to
through a womb again he doesn't he makes
it clear that he's speaking in a more
symbolic way when he speaks in parables
he doesn't we don't really believe there
was a great man who had a banquet and he
invited all the people and they couldn't
come you know we don't really believe
that he's speaking parabolically but the
case of the transubstantiation is
different and we know it's different
because he tells us he's speaking
differently here this is from John the
Jews then disputed among themselves
saying how can this man give us his
flesh to eat so jesus said to them truly
truly I say to you unless you eat the
flesh of the Son of Man and drink his
blood you have no life in you whoever
feeds on my flesh and drinks my blood
has eternal life and I will raise him up
on the last day for my flesh is true
food and my blood is true drink whoever
feeds on my flesh and drinks my blood
abides in me and I in him
it goes on when many of his disciples
heard it they said this is a hard saying
who can listen to it so Jesus responded
knowing in himself that his disciples
were grumbling about this he said do you
take offense at this there is so much
built into this scene about how hard the
saying is that clearly Christ is not
saying this is a symbol and it means
whatever it's a it's a saying that is
very hard to understand it's so hard he
tells us it's hard to understand they
they tell us the people who heard it
tell us it's hard to understand and then
he goes on and says I'm telling you guys
it's real flesh it's real food it's real
blood now
no one questioned the transubstantiation
until centuries like well over a
millennium later after the Protestant
revolution Paul in first corinthians
wrote quote everyone is to recollect
himself before eating this bread and
drinking this cup because a person who
eats and drinks without recognizing the
body is eating and drinking his own
condemnation he says the blessing cup
that we bless is a communion with the
blood of Christ and the bread that we
break is communion with the body of
Christ he clearly believed in the
transubstantiation in the real presence
you
in the in the bread and the wine st.
John Chrysostom wrote we must not
confine our attention to what the census
can experience but hold fast to his
words his word cannot deceive this is
what Christ told us he said I know you
don't understand what I'm saying but I'm
telling you it's true and you're gonna
think it isn't true but it is true
Chrysostom goes on you may not doubt the
truth of this you must rather accept the
Savior's words in faith since he is
truth he does not tell lies the other
reason there are there are many good
arguments for the transubstantiation and
not very good arguments against for the
real presence Martin Luther makes a
great arguments for the real presence of
the body and blood in the wafer but
obviously if you put it under a
microscope I don't know what you would
find that that isn't really the question
that's being said this is why it's a
hard saying but if you think about it
more removed the the beauty of the
transubstantiation the beauty of the
sacraments is is in the is the beauty of
Christ it reflects the beauty of Christ
so at the beginning in the Garden of
Eden the the symbol and the symbolized
the poetry and the criticism were united
and as a civilization developed after
the fall from Eden as civilization moved
on those two became further and further
away the symbol and the symbolized the
the physical and the metaphysical and
the poetry and the criticism as language
evolves we see that this happens this is
what Owen Barfield wrote about in poetic
diction it's what Edwin Bevan wrote
about in symbolism and belief we have to
understand the nature of those symbols
only in Christ only in the Incarnation
do we see this come full circle so the
symbol and the symbolize the poetry in
the criticism separate fully the
metaphysical and the physical until we
have the person of Christ who is fully
God and fully man who unites those two
and he gives us sacraments to to live in
that it's why the saying is so hard it's
why he makes the point of doing it as
his last action before he's put on the
cross he is enshrining this the heaven
and earth touching one another the
metaphysics and the physics touching one
another regularly for the believers and
this is why st. Paul has such joy when
he talks about it in take
so seriously and says that if you don't
recognize this you're eating your own
condemnation there's much more to talk
about the Eucharist but we have to move
on
next question philosopher King Knowles
the USCCB the u.s. Council of Catholic
Bishops recently published a letter in
which they called the new tax plan quote
unconscionable as a devout Catholic I
tend to look to my bishops to inform my
politics but I'm having trouble grasping
their stance this time how can i as a
religious person just to find my support
for the tax bill despite church
leadership condemning it thanks love the
show Zack so with regard to the u.s.
Council of Catholic Bishops I was
talking to a free sprees friend of mine
and he told me that he enjoyed my blank
book reasons to vote for Democrats very
much and he was inspired to write his
own called the wisdom of the u.s.
Council of Catholic Bishops I mean no
disrespect to the bishops but when they
weigh in on politics sometimes they get
a little wacky and I we should obviously
have great reverence for the leaders of
our church especially when they're
speaking on matters of the church and of
theology and of doctrine and when
they're weighing in on politics they
don't have any special political
expertise they don't there aren't
granted special political knowledge or
smarts and so I would I would read them
on other topics before I would read them
on politics and I wouldn't get too
worried about it next question I am
Christian and love the holiday season
however some of my Christian friends say
it is going against scripture to put up
a Christmas tree referring to Jeremiah
10 because it's pagan now I've tried
looking into this but it seems they're
good arguments on both sides
can you explain further and what you
think about it I enjoy having a
Christmas tree however at the same time
I don't want to do something that's
unpleasing to God please help as you
might be able to into it if you
especially few watch the show yesterday
I really like Christmas trees and lights
and Holly and definitely mistletoe you
know but I understand this argument this
comes from Jeremiah there's a line that
says quote a tree from the forest is cut
down and worked with an axe by the hands
of a craftsman they decorate it with
silver and gold they fasten it with
hammer and nails and that is so that it
cannot move their idols are like
scarecrows in a cucumber field and they
cannot speak so he seems to be
describing a Christmas tree or a similar
tradition and so we shouldn't do that
right he tells us not to do that we
shouldn't do that
the issue isn't the tree the issue isn't
the fun little tradition at the holidays
the issue is the idolatry and the issue
is what you invest in that tree so for
instance in the ten commandments God
says to Moses you shall not make a
graven image don't make any graven
images event of anything that is in
heaven
don't make that image because it's an
idol and then about a paragraph later he
tells Moses to create statues of angels
for the orc of the Covenant right he
tells him he said don't make any graven
images and by the way create a work of
art of a thing that's in heaven why is
this it's because of the difference
between idolatry and a piece of art so
if you bring in a Christmas tree because
you're going to worship it and dance
around it and ask all of the gods and
demons to give you a nice presence or
something don't do that that's probably
displeasing to God but if it's a
tradition and you aren't worshipping the
tree you aren't worshipping the graven
image or the picture or the statue it's
there as a reminder as a piece of art
that inspires you to look beyond a tree
or beyond a piece of art toward heaven
toward God himself that's a wonderful
thing and you don't need to worry about
it but I know that it can be scary and
confusing when you see something that
basically says don't have the Christmas
tree and you have to figure out well
what what do they mean by this the the
essence of it is in what you're
worshipping what the culture is looking
to from Jake
how many five-star reviews do I have to
leave for another Kingdom to get to have
a stogie with you and Clavin are you
gonna bring the stogies I'll add it like
one I don't know none it doesn't that's
fine speaking of another Kingdom another
Kingdom is doing very well on iTunes
we're shocked as Hollywood is
figuratively and literally burning to
the ground somehow my podcast with
Andrew Klavan another Kingdom has a shot
to the top and gotten 1200 or 1300
reviews please please go over there and
leave a review and tell your friends and
send it around it really helps us we're
pitching this now to very big people in
television out here it really helps it
would be a great joy to look around the
smoldering of Hollywood if figuratively
I'm speak
of course and to have some conservatives
get a show out of it so please go over
there another kingdom by Andrew Clavin
performed by me that's our show that's
the whole show
go on troops march forward in the war on
Christmas I am Michael Knowles this is
the Michael nul show I will see you on
Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
Haig
supervising producer Mathis Glover our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by mike core amina hair and makeup is by
Jeshua alvera the michael null show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2017